hey everybody I'm here with Michael hi
um and Michael you just played two hours
of hyper scape which is the new battle
royale game from Ubisoft I sure did yep
so up front there's obviously a lot of
very different things about this game
notably its setting is really different
its loot system is really different so
we need to talk about those so tell me
about this loot system how is this
different from other battle Royales yes
if you play battle Royales you're
probably used to the color tier system
with Legendary's epics and like
different levels of quality for loot
hyper escape doesn't differently in
which there are there are weapons and
abilities throughout the map and they're
all the same the thing is that you
upgrade those weapons and abilities by
picking up duplicates of them and they
can level up to up to five times which
if for weapons it increases your
magazine count can increase the output
of the damage for abilities it can cut
down on cooldown time so in a way for me
having played this it kind of changes up
the loot grind a little bit in which you
don't necessarily look for the best
stuff you just want to look for the
stuff that you prefer and then hopefully
over the match you find duplicates of
them so you can upgrade those weapons
and abilities I like to play Apex
legends a lot and I'm usually a shotgun
guy but as we all know the Mozambique is
terrible so like if I could like pick up
three Mozambique's and suddenly that's
like a better thing I would totally do
that
well the the thing is I'll also say is
that hyper scape has a pretty slim
Arsenal which is I mean it keeps its
focus it it's more of an arena shooter
though where it has shotguns assault
rifles grenade launchers rocket
launchers sniper rifle and those sorts
of things so like instead of multiple
different kinds of say sniper rifles
there's just a sniper rifle correct
gotcha okay talk to me about these
abilities too because you don't choose a
character at the top that has like
special abilities right well you choose
a character but it's simply for
aesthetics whichever character you want
to look like their voice lines change
but they're not heroes
they're not like apex legends where they
have abilities tied to them instead
they're called hacks and these are found
on the map as well like they are loot
so what it does for you as a player is
that you can build your loadout with
whatever you find over time I really
came to like the invisibility paired
with the teleport so having those two
abilities because you can equip two at a
time I think those worked really well in
tandem from my style of play but there's
also things like throwing up a wall or
one of the more wild ones is you can
turn into a hamster ball and just like
super high yeah and get across the map
super fast I think that's actually
really useful to get on rooftops quickly
or avoiding firefights in a pinch it
looks absolutely ridiculous but I can
definitely see tactically how it works
can you upgrade those in the same way
that you upgrade weapons like if you
pick up multiple does it get better I
think the main thing that I encountered
I'm not sure if there's other ways they
get upgraded for but for me every time I
upgrade it a hack it shorten the
cooldown so I can use them more
frequently because all of these hacks
slash abilities our subjects are cooled
down rather than being disposable so
that's that definitely something to keep
in mind when you're playing the game
there's obviously a very different lose
system but there's also a different kind
of revive system right yes it's very
different from what you expect from
battle royale I'm still trying to get my
head around whether or not I think it's
better but if the one thing I will say
about it is that it keeps your teammates
invested in the game even after they die
so to kind of lay the groundwork what
happens is that when you die you don't
get knocked down instead you enter this
secondary state where you're invisible
but you can't do anything but run around
the map what that lets you do as a dead
teammate is scout and call out enemy
positions which is a really neat dynamic
of course players who are alive cannot
see you so you never know when you're
being watched opponents when they die
they drop like this triangle pod on the
ground and you're dead teammate means
that go to it and then you go to that to
activate it and revive them to get them
back in the game there's a lot going on
but I think overall it it forces you to
be aggressive because if you want to
revive a teammate then you have to kill
an opponent so they drop that that
little pod where you can revive your
team and also your teammates can be like
a there's there's two around this corner
you can come get them because I see them
there's a lot around the edges that
encourage aggressive play when your
teammate is like dead and invisible like
that is it for a limited time or are
they just like that through the rest of
the match they're like that through the
rest of the match until you revive them
and you can also revive them as many
times as you want like there's no state
in which they die multiple times and
they're completely out of the game so
they're cut as long as they're in the
game they're constantly a factor like I
can already see like a lot of different
levels of strategy with that then yes
you're kind of I imagine you could kind
of decide like okay I can keep this dude
as a spotter but like he can't actually
help me in a firefight right like you
almost choosing when to bring somebody
back is equally important yeah that is
I'm definitely curious to see how that
dynamic is gonna play out as people
start to get their hands on the game cuz
there yeah there are definitely some
strategic elements where you know maybe
you want to keep your teammate dead so
they can invisibly Scout but who knows
the map itself it doesn't have a circle
right it's got something different going
on right we're to use to battle Royales
in which the circle closes in and then
you need to get to the safe zone there's
still an element of that but the way it
works is that the map is broken up into
distinct districts like little chunks of
the map will get closed off as the match
progresses but it's designed in a way so
it's just like this chunk of map is
subject to being eliminated from the map
as the as it progresses so it's not like
you're gonna the circle is gonna close
you in on a specific building and cut
you off in an awkward way so it's very
deliberate in which the map is designed
so that you know players can react to it
a little bit more predictably I guess
and you said before it kind of feels
like in arena shooters so like war zone
is obviously very much Call of Duty apex
plays a lot like titanfall what what
does this feel like when you're playing
it good question I think as an
old-school arena shooter player I was
reminded of Unreal Tournament and quake
I think it's because the the way the
weapons work and the way that time to
kill is it's a pretty high time to kill
so you know in battle Royales like if
you get caught off guard you're probably
gonna get showered on with like bullets
and then you'll die before you can
react but here because it's high time to
kill and because there's so much
mobility like it's an arena shooter it
definitely feels like like I'm in and
making an encounter in unreal
so there's double jumps there's jump
pads there's a lot of verticality in the
map that's designed around the buildings
that you fight around and in the streets
and like my favorite weapon is probably
the the rocket launcher which is you
know it functions like a rocket launcher
an intervenor shooter so it takes like
three or four rockets to kill an enemy
so it's not like this super powerful
weapon instead it's like I'm aiming at
the ground to predict where they're
gonna land so then I can get the splash
damage on them three to four Rockets
like definitely sounds like a lot I mean
to me that sounds fun being on it's like
kind of weak is it does it feel like
that with the other weapons it does I
think that's the my main critique of the
game as it stands is that the shooting
mechanics do lack some sort of impact
the way the gun fights will play out
like I said reminding me of Unreal
Tournament but the fact that the
shooting doesn't feel like it it's its
packing a punch is a missed opportunity
at the end of the day this is a
first-person shooter so if the shooting
mechanics fall short that's a big deal
to me but you don't have to actually
like kill everyone to win though right
yeah eh that's a good transition right
there
but yeah so you don't necessarily have
to be the last one standing in hyper
scape because there's this there's this
mechanic called the crown so I think
once it's down to about five or four
squads a crown will spawn on the map and
it's sort of this like we've seen this
style of mode and other shooters but you
someone grabs it you hold on to it for a
certain amount of time and if you can
hold on to it for that amount of time
that you win so in hyper scale if you
grab the crown and you hold on to it for
forty-five seconds without dying you'll
automatically win you don't have to kill
the rest of the squads this is another
way in which the game is an encouraging
aggressive style of play because once
you grab the crown your your position is
then available to all the remaining
players
so they're gonna be tracking you down
trying to kill you so everyone's gonna
converge on this wherever the crown
carrier is and it can get pretty wild I
won my match through having the crown
and in the last like 20 seconds of
holding on to it all a Squatch is
converged on my team and then we just
posted up yeah it's pretty wild and my
teammates were all trying to defend me
yeah like most of the time Abby our game
is like it's essentially a hardcore team
deathmatch right you know at the end of
the day but this is like capture the
flag what you just described yeah that's
cool I mean so do you think that's
enough then to like really grab your
interest or do you still feel just kind
of burned out cuz like you know Real
Talk there are a lot of battle rail
games out there right now yeah that's a
fair that's a fair assessment and I
think that's gonna be the question on a
lot of people's minds or that'll be
their first impression when they when
they see this game is that another
battle royale and I get that too a sense
the thing I will give hyper escape a lot
of credit for going the links to trying
to be something different rather than
Ubisoft saying oh we want a piece of the
pie as well I was like well what do you
bring to the table and from what I've
experienced and from what I've seen so
far these are genuinely different types
of mechanics for Battle Royale but I
definitely want to see light like I said
about the gunplay I want to see some
improvements there if you're tired of
battle Royales and the the thing that
you're most concerned about is just you
know the stress of trying to be the last
one standing or getting one life to live
after looting and stuff there are some
things around the edges of the game that
can improve that experience do you know
when where other people are gonna be
able to play it I think Ubisoft has more
to share later on but yeah you got to
keep your eyes peeled for that because
you know here on GameSpot we're gonna
tell you all that information straight
up definitely all right well thanks
Michael guys we'll catch you later when
we have more to say about hyper scape
[Music]